summarization of data is still important
perhaps summarization not down to a
single scalar value but looking at that
whole c of numbers you have to
find
patterns like what is inflation in a
particular sector what is maybe uh
change over time maybe different
geographical regions
you know
things of that nature i think that's
kind of i don't know even what that task
is uh you know that's what you could
look at machine learning you can look at
ai with that perspective which is like
how do you represent
what's happening efficiently
as efficiently as possible that's never
going to be a single number but it might
be a compressed model that captures
something
something beautiful something
fundamental about what's happening
it's an opportunity
for sure
right um
you know
if we take um for example during the
pandemic
the
the response of the political apparatus
was to lower interest rates to zero
and to start to
start buying assets in essence printing
money
and the defense was there's no inflation
but of course you had one part of the
economy where it was locked down so it
was illegal to buy anything
but you couldn't you know it was either
illegal or it was impractical
so it would be impossible for demand to
manifest so of course there is no
inflation
on the other hand
there was instantaneous immediate
inflation in another part of the economy
for example um
you lowered the interest rates uh to
zero one point we saw the uh the swap
rate on the 30-year note go to 72 basis
points
okay that means that the value of a long
dated bond immediately inflates so the
bond market had hyper inflation within
minutes
of these uh
financial decisions the asset market had
hyperinflation
we had what you call a case shape
recovery what we affectionately call a
shake k-shape recovery main street
shutdown wall street recovered all
within six weeks
the inflation was in the assets
like in the stocks and the bonds
uh
you know if you look today you see that
uh
typical house according to case-shiller
index today is up 19.2 percent
year-over-year
so
if you're a first time home buyer the
inflation rate is 19 percent
uh the formal cpi announced is 7.9
percent
you can pretty much
create any inflation rate you want by
constructing a market basket a weighted
basket of products or services or assets
that yield you the answer
i think that
you know the fundamental failing of
economists is is first of all
they don't really have a term for asset
inflation
right uh what's an asset what's asset
hyperinflation you mentioned bond market
swap rate and asset is the where the all
majority of the hyperinflation happen
what's inflation what's hyperinflation
what's an asset what's an asset market
i'm going to ask so many dumb questions
in the conventional economic world you
would you would treat inflation as uh
the rate of increase in price of a
market basket of consumer products
defined by a government agency
so they have a like traditional things
that a regular consumer would be buying
you the government selects like toilet
paper
food
toaster
refrigerator electronics all that kind
of stuff and it's like a representative
a basket of goods
that lead to a content existence on this
earth for a regular consumer they define
a synthetic metric right i mean i i'm
going to say you should have a thousand
square foot apartment and you should
have
a used car and you should eat you know
three hamburgers a week
now 10 years go by and the apartment
costs more
i could adjust the market basket
by a you know they call them hedonic
adjustments i could decide that it used
to be in 1970 to 1 000 square feet but
in the year 2020 you only need 700
square feet because we've many
miniaturized televisions
and we've got more efficient electric
appliances and because things have
collapsed into the iphone you just don't
need as much space
so now i you know it may be that the
apartment costs 50 more but after the
hedonic adjustment there is no inflation
because i just downgraded the
expectation of what a normal person
should have so the synthetic nature of
the metric allows for manipulation
by people in power
pretty much
i guess my criticism of economist is
rather than embracing inflation
based upon its fundamental idea which is
the rate at which the price of things go
up
right
they've been captured
by
mainstream conventional thinking to
immediately equate inflation to
the government-issued cpi or
government-issued pce or
government-issued ppi measure which
was never the rate at which things go up
it's simply the rate at which a
synthetic basket of
products and services the government
wishes to track go up
now the problem with that
is is
two big things one thing is
the government gets to create the market
basket and so they keep changing what's
in the basket
over time
so i mean if
if i keep tr if i said three years ago
you should go see ten concerts a year
and the concert tickets now cost two
hundred dollars each now it's two
thousand dollars a year to go see
concerts
now i'm in charge of calculating
inflation so i redefine you know your
entertainment quota for the year to be
eight netflix streaming concerts and now
they don't cost two thousand dollars
they cost nothing and there is no
inflation but you don't get your
concerts right so the problem starts
with
continually changing the definition of
the market basket but in my opinion
that's not the biggest problem
the more
the more egregious problem
is the the fundamental idea that assets
aren't products or services
assets can't be inflated with an asset a
house
a share of apple stock
um a bond
um any a bitcoin is an asset um or uh a
picasso painting
so
not a consumable good
not a uh not not not an apple that you
can eat
right if i throw away an asset
then uh i'm not on the hook to track the
inflation rate for it so
what happens if i change the policy such
that
let's take the class example a million
dollar bond at a five percent interest
rate gives you fifty thousand dollars a
year in risk-free income
you might retire on fifty thousand
dollars a year in a low cost
jurisdiction
so the cost of social security or early
retirement is one million dollars when
the interest rate is five percent
uh during the the crisis of march of
2020 the interest rate went on a 10-year
bond went to 50 basis points
okay so now the cost of that bond is 10
million dollars
okay the cost of social security went
from a million dollars to 10 million
dollars
so if you wanted to work your entire
life save money and then retire risk
free and live happily ever after on a 50
000 salary living on a beach in mexico
wherever you wanted to go
you had hyperinflation the cost of your
aspiration increased by a factor of 10
over the course of
you know some amount of time in fact
in that case that was like over the
course of about 12 years
right as the inflation rate ground down
the asset traded up but the you know the
conventional view is oh that's not a
problem because it's good that that
assets it's good that the bond is highly
priced because we own the bond
or um
what's the problem with the inflation
rate in housing being 19
it's an awful problem for a 22 year old
that's starting their first job that's
saving money to buy a house
but it would be characterized as a
benefit to society by a conventional
economist who would say well housing
asset values are higher because of
interest rate fluctuation and now the
economy's got more wealth
and uh and so that's that's viewed as a
benefit
so the
what's being missed here
like the suffering of the average person
or the
uh the struggle the suffering the pain
of the average person
like metrics that captured that within
the economic system is that is it when
you talk about one way to say it is a
conventional
view of inflation as cpi understates the
human misery that's in inflicted upon
the working class and and on uh
mainstream companies
uh
by uh
by the political class and so it's a
massive shift of wealth from the working
class to the property class
it's a massive shift of power from the
free market uh to the
centrally governed or the controlled
market
it's a massive shift of power from the
people to the government and and
maybe one one
more illustrative point here alexis
is uh what do you think the inflation
rate's been for the past hundred years
oh you talking about the scalar again if
you if you took a survey of everybody on
the street and you asked them what do
they think inflation was uh what is it
you know
you remember when jerome powell said our
target's two percent but we're not there
if you go
around the corner i have uh posted the
deed to this house sold in nineteen
thirty
okay and uh
the number on that deed is one hundred
thousand dollars
nineteen thirty and if you go on zillow
and you get the z estimate is it higher
than that no 30 million 500 thousand
dollars yeah so
that's uh 92 years 1930 or 2022
and
and in 92 years we've had
305 x increase in price of the house
now if you actually back calculate you
can you come to a conclusion that the
inflation rate was approximately six and
a half percent a year
every year for 92 years
okay and and there's nobody
nobody in government no conventional
economist that would ever admit to an
inflation rate of seven percent a year
in the u.s dollar over the last century
now
if you if you uh dig deeper i mean one
one guy that's done a great job working
on this is safety namos who wrote who
wrote the book the bitcoin standard and
he notes that on average it looks like
uh the inflation rate and the money
supply is about seven percent a year
all the way up to the year 2020.
if you look at the s p index which is a
market basket of scarce desirable
stocks it returned about 10 percent
if you talk to 10 percent a year for 100
years
the money supply is expanding at 7
percent 100 years
if you actually talk to economists or
you look at the the economy and you ask
the question how fast does the economy
grow
in its entirety year over year
generally about two to three percent
like the sum total impact of all this
technology and human ingenuity
might get you a two and a half three
percent improvement a year as measured
by gdp
is that are you okay with that not sure
i'm not sure i'd go that far yet but i
would just say that
if you had the human race doing stuff
yeah
and if you ask the question how much
more efficiently will we do the stuff
next year than this year or how what's
the value of all of our
innovations and inventions and
investments in the past 12 months
you'd be hard-pressed to say we get two
percent better
typical investor thinks they they're 10
percent better every year
so if you look at what's going on really
when you're holding a million dollars of
stocks and you're getting a ten percent
gain a year you really get a seven
percent
expansion of the money supply
you're getting a two or three percent
gain under best circumstances
and
another way to say that is if the money
supply stopped expanding at seven
percent a year the s p yield might be
three percent and not ten percent it
probably should be
now that that gets you to start to ask a
bunch of other fundamental questions
like
if i borrow a billion dollars and pay
three percent interest and the money
supply expands at seven to ten percent a
year and
i ended up making a ten percent return
on a you know billion dollar investment
paying three percent interest is that
fair
and who who suffered
so that i could do that because
in an environment where you're just
inflating the money supply and you're
holding the assets constant
it stands the reason that the price of
all the assets is going to appreciate
somewhat proportional to the money
supply
and the difference in asset
appreciations is going to be a function
of the scarce desirable quality of the
assets and to what extent can i make
more of them and to what extent are they
are they truly limited in supply
you